[Music]
from Steven Spielberg director of films
about the Holocaust and Japanese
internment camps but also the fun side
of World War II don't you
boy that was fun comes another one about
his favorite real war with a fake story
about a real policy and fake characters
asking if they really have to do this
where's the sense of risking the lives
of the eight of us to save one guy it's
not going to be easy finding one
particular soldier in the middle of this
whole goddamn woman this entire mission
is a serious misallocation of valuable
military resources this
we understand what you're doing
yes you do
Saving Private Ryan
return to a time when punching Nazis
wasn't controversial and witnessed the
reason your grandpa doesn't talk very
much that's a realistic look at the
sacrifice of the troops on the ground
and the armchair generals who send them
off to die for extremely dumb reasons we
go sending some sort of Rescue Mission
they're going to be kia2 we are going to
send somebody to find them in this
search and rescue mission where an
entire Squad lays down their lives so
Matt Damon's mom can be one quarter less
sad no one Damon's worth eight other
guys besides we got a spare
[Music]
strap in for some of the most punishing
battle scenes of all time
that opens with a meat grinder that was
D-Day
and continues an unflinching mix of the
History Channel and Mortal Kombat
fatalities
featuring more nervous looking dudes
than the waiting room at a vasectomy
clinic
and more grown men sobbing than at the
end of Terminator 2.
foreign
[Music]
this film was intense can we light it up
a bit dude
suit up for a film that honors the
troops and the troops with standard
issue characters like tough guy from
Brooklyn I'm done with this Mission
religious Southerner God gave me a
special gift made me a fine instrumental
Warfare wisecracking Jew
anxious rookie
famous actor Cameo and in a Visionary
piece of casting Vin Diesel as an
Italian guy with a crucifix necklace who
cares deeply about family
ain't no such thing as a master race and
if there was I would win it race Wars
we invented it
leading them into the depths of hell is
America's dad Tom Hanks he's one part
weapons geek Sprint mine 44 streamline
42's pot mines a200s big mushrooms
telemine 43s one part MacGyver
two mg-42 two Motors we could try a
sticky bomb so are you making that up
and one part guy ashamed of his liberal
arts degree something with stories
probably did for a living I teach
English composition salute this hero who
seems almost too good to be true he's
good I love him then realize wait if
this whole story is private Ryan's
flashback everything before they meet up
is just his imagination Ryan wasn't
there on D-Day he never even met waiter
compazo he probably just fell asleep
watching Boiler Room he's definitely I
don't want to hear a kid okay
so revisit one of the greatest most
accurate War films ever made that's come
to define the conflict for Generations
until the Call of Duty franchise came
along and honestly this movie proves Cod
got it mostly right too the Chad is full
of bro talk
with a hunk of cheese in your ass
comparison you smart ass I thought you
liked yes the teamwork is non-existent
maybe I should go left sir maybe you
should shut up and if you kill enough of
the other side without dying you get to
call in an epic kill streak
come on it's so op they have to Nerf
those planes in World War III
[Music]
starring look at me I'm the captain now
the dirt Locker
Brooklyn wine wine Jackson 316 says I
just shut your ass Fubar Mitzvah I don't
got a squad I got family what's up ham
Giovanni riblizi
Bland of Brothers
Malone in the dark Army of one and Paul
gianazzi
National platoons European formation
[Music]
you know it's really rare when a film
honors the greatest generation and
inspires the greatest porn name of a
generation I mean even Spielberg had to
give it props shaving Ryan's privates
did you know about this uh no
not until this very moment wow
air hockey is the best Olympic sport
hope all since ping pong
and apple a day keeps the doctor away
but what if you are the doctor
I'm the Epic voice guy
sexy chimichangas